our bachelor is back he wasn't our
bachelor but we've got an update and he
was never in any way our bachelor but
he's dating someone from the franchise
it's time for roses and rose day you
guys I don't have any rose day yes
everyone my name is lauren zima and I
forgot Rosie can you believe it have I
ever committed such a sin but here's the
thing I've got the next best thing
another favorite drug of choice not a
sponsor but I'm gonna say their name cuz
they'll probably never sponsor us diet
coke this is perfect cuz I'm so tired
and it really gives that caffeine boost
that even coffee can't I've also learned
that a whole can of Diet Coke fits in
this wineglass Wow every day I can't
believe I forgot the Rose everybody I'm
so sorry but you know what it's okay
because I didn't forget any of the big
bachelor news we talked about this last
week so much bachelor news is happening
you guys what story has made you go the
most I can't tell what you guys want
some people say in the comments that you
want more like bachelor recap old show
like mashups of moments and then some
people like no just the news and you
know what I just have the news I only
have time for the news so much news is
happening I'm up at 5 a.m. these days no
really 4:30 I have to be at work at 5:00
I roll out of bed at 4:45 I brush my
teeth maybe I throw my glasses on I have
to be at et live ok please watch it
shameless plug just last week we
interviewed Vanessa Grimaldi and Taylor
Nolan okay I'm having bachelor people I
mean okay shameless plug
ah that's a good burn anyway let's get
to bachelor news you can booze even if
your booze is a very chemically
concoction what's in diet coke what is
it whatever mm-hmm not grape so I'll
tell you that much
all right everybody he's back yes Colton
Underwood has returned to social media
our bachelor is back to us after being
on a hiatus since September and by a
hiatus I mean filming the show he was
filming the show that's where he was he
was filming duh Colton came back with a
very subtle I'm back he tweeted he said
hello it's me with a fun little Adele
gift he put up a sexy picture of himself
and he got a lot of support from
bachelor nation pals in the comment
sections Jordan Kimball said quote you
made it out alive there's a question
remember when I interviewed Ben Higgins
and Mick
violet iHeartRadio they said that the
process would quote destroy him
we'll see him struggle and I think we've
seen all of us struggle through it but I
think Colton really cares so I think
we'll see this thing like I think we'll
see his most authentic this might be the
most authentic and genuine and most
transparent season that we've ever had
because I just think he's I think he's
gonna feel it did the show eat you guys
alive yeah it definitely destroyed me
wow I've never been the same
okay that's what happened this is why I
don't drink diet coke on here
a very gassy person something in me
thinks that if I do this I feel more
legit like an old school news man
all right out in the field I don't know
anyway
Colton has returned to us by doing very
Colton things he is reunited with his
dog hi and he's been working out drink
every time Colton does something Colton
II mmm I'm excited to watch him guys I
set it on reality sees podcast I'll say
it again I think it's going to be good
television also Colton's first promo
poster was out and in aunt shockingly
they make a little nod to his virginity
what does he have to lose I'll be honest
it took me a minute to get that joke and
I was disappointed myself and is it a
joke what do you guys think should we be
joking about Colton's virginity
Chris Harrison recently said in an
interview that Colton's reason for being
a virgin is more than he thought that it
also has to do with prior relationships
and experiences that was an interesting
take to me what do you think should we
be joking about it I feel like jokes
will be made on the show it certainly is
going to be used on the promos I don't
necessarily think it's funny
hmmm what does he have to lose
Colton by the way returning also with
some deep thoughts he tweeted it's easy
to hate what you don't understand
it's so deep I'm drowning what do you
guys think he was talking about what's
your friend to let me know in the
comments breaking breaking breaking I'm
broken guys breaking news hold the
presses read all about it yes I thought
that I'd covered all the bachelor news
but just hours after we finished taping
roses and Rosie
ABC dropped the first footage from
Colton's season
[Applause]
yes of course we had to come out and
address it so I'm not in the rows and
rows they set up I don't have any row
say again one a week but we had to talk
about the first teaser so let's break it
down of course we get Colton shirtless
why don't we think of this right off the
top I mean he's not really my type
I'm not into like the Ken doll vibe I've
never dated a blonde but you know what
he looks great he looks fit wonderful
applause to Colton and obviously the
ladies are very into it and of course we
get them crying and we get trauma and we
get talk about Colton's virginity I am a
virgin virginity virginity yes we know
this is going to be a plotline but then
things escalate holy
Colten good question lady I don't know I
do know that it seems unless they really
sped up that footage golden freaking
jumps offence in one fell swoop icon
Underwood superhero spider-man jumping
man dog superhero lovin guy I don't know
what was on the other side of that fence
puppies was he trying to save them look
that was intense and got me so excited
for this season what did you guys think
of the trailer I'm all about it I'm
totally in and here's the moment I
really want to highlight other than the
fence jump like look by the way that
that audio of that woman as he jumps
over the fence I think that's from
another moment I think that that's like
super imposed upon it but I'm here for
the drama and also for Chris Harrison
saying holy holy yeah just Chris hair
hasn't it in the dark it really ups the
ante doesn't it calling after Colton but
the moment I want to highlight is Colton
crying and hugging what looks like a
producer in this green jacket yes I
don't think that's a contestant that
person is dressed like they're a crew
member and those tears look very real
now we know from Paradise Colton's a
crier but why would he be hugging and
crying a producer why would he say that
he is scared
I think Colton makes a really intense
personal revelation this season that is
my prediction based on this trailer and
I'm very excited to see what happens
this season what do you guys think what
do you think of the trailer did it get
you stoked for Colton's season let me
know now back to our regularly scheduled
okay bounce right back next up another
new Z boozy update the inside of the
bachelor mansion as I told you guys is
okay after all the wildfires and only 18
teeth yes I helped book this went inside
the mansion with the owner and he showed
us all around told us exactly what's
happened to the property and what he
will be fixing up again remember the
show had already filmed all the mansion
scenes so we're good for this season you
can check that fully out at ET online
waking right back up for some of you
have asked me to do an update on Peter
Krause the Peter Krause you know I love
him the man who we wanted to be the
bachelor and instead we got well
unexpected Peter Krause is returning to
our TVs on ease total divas total fellas
why he's allegedly dating Nikki Bella
III don't understand it Peter I don't
know if I'm ready for this so Peter is
on drinks every time I do that careful
that was three Lauren stop please drink
responsibly so Peter is on total Bella's
and he's seemingly going on a date with
Nikki who is single after dating John
Cena I mean I'll be honest guys this
seems like a bit of a TV ploy to me but
you know Peter hey take gigs you can get
and do your thing sure why not
I don't think they're really dating do
you think the Peter Krause and Nikki
Bella are really dating it's a no for me
now there's also a rumor that perhaps
Peter is dating Nick Vile's ex Vanessa
Grimaldi
and it's all because Peter was in
Seattle where Vanessa and Taylor Nolan
are besties and living together I think
are hanging out a lot or something and
he went and painted a picture with them
I don't buy it
they don't look very affectionate in
this photo and I just talked to Vanessa
and Taylor via Skype from this houseboat
they're living on and Vanessa said that
they are dating each other girl power
friendship what do you guys think or
Peter Krause and Vanessa Grimaldi dating
I drink every time here Peter Krause
dating rumor okay from dating to babies
and bachelor bachelorette parties it's
REM Lauren yeah Ari and Lauren everybody
did surprise the world I did not see
this coming when they revealed on
Instagram their son know Graham they are
expecting a baby due in June 2019 after
their wedding in January 2019 and then
over the weekend in Las Vegas they both
celebrated bachelor bachelorette parties
ahead of that wedding you know what look
what do I have to say to them
congratulations at the end of the day a
baby is always a blessing as my mother
Donna used to say I'm not sure if she
still does say that mom what do you
think now that world are you still glad
you had his kids she doesn't watch this
show I'll tell you that anyway and at
Lauren's bachelorette party is some
familiar bachelor nation faces a cien
Fleming was their aunt I did not see
this coming
Jenna Cooper okay
had to lay down for a lot of this news
today Jenna was there with purple hair I
did not know Jenna and Lauren were
friends but they are I guess and this is
after Jenna posted in a black wig on
Instagram and I just want to read her
caption from when she recently posted on
Instagram and a different hair color and
a black wig this is
saying with Jenna and Jordan it's just
with Jenna today though she says when
you feel an extra dramatic on a
Wednesday I guess that you wear a black
wig when you're feeling extra dramatic
and I'm feeling I stir dramatic I just
have here like a freaking doll what is
up with this hair I'm like a Shirley
Temple cosplayer today also look at my
arm it's like this is the camera guys
sometimes it's like I'm really just not
happy of my self and then sometimes it's
like oh damn she's been working out it's
all about the angle
anyway so Jenna on instagram in her
black wig when you feel an extra
dramatic on a Wednesday just left a fun
shoot now heading home to warm up frozen
burritos and live the dream you know
what that is the tree but then she says
I wanted to remind everyone that if you
or your friends and family need any help
with mitigation mold damage or
demolition visit flood pros usa.com
that's the thing about Jenna's Instagram
post they take so many hard left and
right turns
it's like black wig feeling dramatic
getting my frozen burrito don't forget
to deal with your mold at home floods
pro usa.com what I have to say the most
creative Instagram ads I've ever seen
creative it's nonsensical however you
want to look at it now from mitigation
mold to the red carpet everybody we yes
et broke the news that Lauren Bushnell
and Chris Lane are dating how does
everyone feel let me know what do you
think of this relationship I wanted
cheers to you know just happiness they
seems to be dating newly after being
friends for a while at least that's what
they told us and you know looking great
on the red carpet at the CMAs so there
were some observations that that you had
been flirting for a while they were
getting all up in each other's Instagram
comments and then we did do some digging
and found out yes they are dating and
then at the CMAs we just asked Chris
Lane you know a couple of questions
about his new gal here's what he had to
say this is a newfound thing and I can
finally say I found my tape back home
girl so wrap to them and by the way how
freaking amazing is Lauren look I love
that dress her body is gorgeous her face
is gorgeous everything is gorgeous Chris
Lane by the way in case you forgot has
appeared on The Bachelor before he sang
on it
[Music]
small world small small bachelor world
harsh transition drink every time
there's a harsh transition Oh Ben
Higgins everybody yeah him and Lauren
Bushnell nothing to do with each other
no didn't make that transition for any
reason okay
so Ben I just want to say in bachelor
news is starting up several new ventures
he's opened the restaurant which he'd
been telling you for a while is a dream
of his he'd been working on this and
it's finally open Congrats Ben and he
has launched a venture called the
wedding party I think and he is just a
busy busy bee so congrats DeBaun also
doing so much with his charity humanity
and hope and generous coffee I don't
know how he does it all
okay everybody that's what's happening
in bachelor news you can booze by the
way anything I had Aspen at iHeartRadio
if in the morning would ever get back
together after she became single in
August for breaking with a boyfriend
Devin his lease at that time you know I
don't think our lives have gone any
closer than they were a year and a half
ago you know if maybe when they were
aligning or their crop we were crossing
paths or we have spoken I would say
though there's a shot but we've
continued to go like this and so i would
say i don't i don't see that path there
that possibility happening at this point
so he said it and they're not together
and she's dating Chris Lane and what do
you guys think should then be the
bachelor again it's been talked about so
much I know we're about to embark on our
new season with Colton which I am
excited for but should bang be the
bachelor again if he's still single in
about a year what do you think you said
he would maybe do it let me know guys
I'm an idiot I'm watching myself right
now on roses and I forgot the whole
reason I was bringing up Ben is because
I got an exclusive interview with him
and that's available DT online.com and
he talks he's dating live
and and so much more shameless plug
thanks JC okay everybody even a Scrooge
like me can't forget that it's the
holiday season how do I not forget
because JC reminds me so since this is
Thanksgiving week I just wanted to say
thank you all so much for watching the
show for sending me videos of you
drinking your wine I love it so much
tell me what you're thankful for this
year are you thankful for rose' is there
anything that you love as much as wine
like I do love diet coke are you
thankful for things other than wine it's
just hard to even imagine I do want to
say I am also thankful for JC come out
here JC tell me something boys you can't
run away um a star is born always in my
head and JC you are a star in my life I
just wanted to say thank you truly for
lifting me up every Monday you guys with
film roses in rows a once a week a JC
like reminds me of things I'm supposed
to say and do
reminds me of what day it is spends
hours on the video everyone you're
making it so good and funny I would be
nothing without him so G seems so cool
and as a reminder he's single JC tell me
something boy are you tired
Stacy I mean Jackson do you want to say
anything to the people
happy Thanksgiving we love you we
appreciate you we appreciate the
comments I appreciate this person you're
so so much without her I wouldn't be
here on this stage everybody be at peace
and we'll see you next week we love you
guys thank you
[Music]